vas caminando por la calle y de pronto
alguien te aborda y te dice es necesito
tu ayuda por favor esto es urgente
necesito saber si 4792 es un número
divisible entre 3 y como tú conoces una
técnica para saber si un número es
divisible entre 3 recuerdas que solo
basta sumar los dígitos de este número y
si el número que obtenemos es divisible
entre 3 entonces este número es
divisible entre 3 por lo que haces 4 + 7
+ 9 + 2 y esto es igual a 4 7 11 9 20 +
2 22 pero 22 no parece ser un número de
hecho no es un número divisible entre 3
y para comprobarlo recuerdas que también
si tuvieras dudas puedes sumar los
dígitos de lo que obtuviste ósea
+ 2 que son los dígitos del 22 2 más 2
es igual a 4 y definitivamente este
número no es divisible entre 3 pero
cumpliste tu tarea has ayudado a esta
persona sigues caminando muy tranquilo
por la calle y de pronto otra persona
taborda y te dice hey necesito tu ayuda
estoy en una gran emergencia y necesito
saber si el número 386 1802 es un número
divisible entre 3 pero otra vez aplica
esta idea que tú ya conoces que es sumar
todos los dígitos de este número y si el
resultado es un número que es divisible
entre 3 entonces este número es un
número divisible entre 3 y ahí vamos
entonces hay que hacer 3 más 8 más 6 más
8 + 0 + 2 en que esto va que será igual
bueno 3 más 8 son 11 las 6 17 más 8 25
más 2 27
definitivamente el 27 es un número
divisible entre 3 y para despejar
cualquier duda y comprobar el resultado
recuerda que también podemos sumar los 2
dígitos del número que obtuvimos y si
este número es divisible entre 3 bueno
se sigue aplicando la misma regla o sea
que 2 + 7 los dígitos de 27 es igual a 9
y definitivamente estamos en un número
que es divisible entre 3
así que 386 1802 es divisible entre 3 y
una vez más ayudaste a una persona para
salvarlo de esta gran emergencia en la
que se encontraba
mientras sigues caminando te viene a la
mente la duda porque será que este
método que yo conozco para la
divisibilidad entre 3 funciona así que
se te ocurre lo siguiente pueden tomar
un número al azar son por ejemplo el 498
y antes de aplicar la técnica que hemos
estado describiendo y vamos a trabajar
las cosas ahora de una manera diferente
es decir voy a tomar los números por sus
posiciones o sea el 4 que está en la
posición de las centenas y lo voy a
reescribir digamos el cuarto es 4 % pero
yo no quiero reescribir de una manera
particular o sea que sea 4 que está
haciendo x 1 + 99 estarás de acuerdo que
199 es 100 y por 4 400 y es exactamente
4 en la posición de las centenas después
vamos a tomar al 9 que está en las
decenas y lo vamos a reescribir como 9
por 10 pero el día esto voy a escribir
como uno más 99 más uno son 10 por 9 son
90 y es lo que tenemos aquí en un 9 en
la posición de las decenas y finalmente
pues el 8 no le podemos hacer muchas
cosas porque está en las unidades
simplemente lo reescribimos
voy a tratar de reorganizar aquí un poco
mi espacio de trabajo y voy a amor
sí sí sí es posible vamos a mover tanto
es perfecto ya estamos
ya estamos listos entonces ahora
el asunto que queremos hacer ahora es
distribuir es decir en primero voy a
trabajar con este término que está aquí
y voy a distribuir el 4 que está
multiplicando al 1 y el 4 que está
multiplicando al 99 o sea esto va a ser
igual a 44 por unos 4 + 4 que multiplica
a 99 el siguiente que voy a trabajar es
este 9
lo voy a distribuir el 9 por 1 y el 9
por 9 9 por 13 9 + 9 x
de acuerdo y obviamente nuestro amigo el
8 pues pasa intacto de este lado ahora
lo siguiente que voy a hacer es
reagrupar los términos que tengo en toda
esta expresión entonces a ver vamos a
seleccionar un color que no hemos usado
por ejemplo el verde entonces los que yo
quiero reagrupar son este término que
está aquí y este término que está aquí
entonces ahora los voy a poner como 4
por 99 observa que cambien la anotación
pero estamos hablando de productos y es
lo mismo nada más es diferente notación
más 9 que está haciendo x 9 entonces ya
tengo este y este y ahora regreso con
los que ella tenía no entonces está el
41 esto es lo mismo que sumarle 4 ahora
vamos con este 9 más 9 y el 8 de las
unidades más 8 entonces lo siguiente que
ahora vamos a estamos analizando
esta forma de trabajar identificar es lo
siguiente entonces
analicemos este término que está aquí
entonces el 99 definitivamente es un
número divisible en t3 y
independientemente porque el número yo
lo multiplique el resultado de esa
multiplicación va a ser divisible en t3
o sea que esto es divisible entre 3
luego este término que tengo de este
lado también es divisible entre 3 porque
lo estoy multiplicando por 9 de acuerdo
entonces no importa el que esté de este
lado el resultado el producto de esta
operación va a ser divisible entre 3 así
que todo lo que yo tengo de este lado es
divisible entre 3
esto es divisible entre 3 muy bien ahora
sólo tengo que pensar y trabajar con lo
que resta los términos de este lado es
decir que la suma de estos términos sea
un número divisible entre 3 lo que
tenemos que encontrar es que la suma de
los términos que están de este lado sea
algo divisible entre 3 o sea lo
importante es que esto tiene
que ser
divisible
entre 3 y con esto hemos terminado